I know why you're all excited tonight
because tonight's the big State of the
Union address you're safe wow you are a
good crowd biggest lie I have ever heard
remember Colin's gonna bring up the city
you did go crazy yeah now here's the
problem we're supposed to sort of talk
about it cuz it's gonna happen tonight
right but it hasn't happened yet for us
we we taped the show a couple of hours
early we do we we go to bed very early
yeah I'm in bed by 9 o'clock this show
tonight's show was taped in 2016 yeah
Trump's not gonna win there's no way
that's happening same thing we're taping
just a couple of hours before tonight's
the Union address so we don't know
what's gonna happen we did just get a
copy of the speech they released a copy
and right now we're having a researcher
fact check president Trump's speech
let's take a look at him
[Applause]
Wow that that was just the first line
that was the state of the union is
strong
- boom I can guess so it's we can try
and guess what's gonna happen tonight
I'm gonna make a crazy wild assumption
I'm gonna guess that tonight Trump once
once mentions the wall don't you think
just one time I think the speech might
just be him going yeah we know that
Nancy Pelosi is going to be sitting
behind him we know that's gonna happen
and that's historic because it'll be the
first time Trump's been photographed
with a woman over 40
[Applause]
when there's one I like I like to force
some of the audience to congratulate me
in person you know there's this
tradition of the first lady the first
lady and gets to invite a guest that's a
big deal to stay at the Union do you
know who First Lady Melania Trump's
guest is gonna be at the State of the
Union do you know this this is true an
11 year old boy who got bullied because
his last name is Trump yeah I know I
felt bad for the kid too until I found
out he declared bankruptcy ten times he
won yeah he's
yeah he's only 11 years old he cheated
on his first wife with his second life
Wow he runs a fraudulent University out
of this kid
as kids trouble